[Music]
hi it's Michelle from Lambeth and beauty
science chemistry PhD and fan of
science-based skincare products today
I'm talking about my cell waters I've
told about the science behind micellar
waters before in a previous video but
today's video focuses on why you need to
cleanse your skin why my cell waters
might be suitable for you and why they
might not be suitable for you this video
is sponsored by Bioderma the science
heavy french-german cosmetic brand that
invented micellar water back in 1991
you've probably heard of their sense if
I own my cell water which is a cult
product that makeup artists love if you
like the sort of video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to my channel and click the
notification bell so you don't miss any
of my videos the first step in any
skincare routine is cleansing cleansing
is really important you want to get rid
of any remnants of products that you
applied earlier in the day or the
previous day
you also want to get rid of excess oil
dirt germs and dead skin cells that are
left on the surface of your skin
otherwise all this stuff left on your
skin can be irritating it can lead to
breakouts it can also stop other
products from working and it can make
your skin look dull unfortunately you
can't just wash your face with plain
water and the reason is a lot of the
things you're trying to remove are oil
soluble and as you probably know oil and
water don't dissolve in each other in
almost all cleansers you'll find
ingredients called surfactants so
factors help oil dissolve in water
surfactants are the key ingredients in
gel cleansers foaming cleansers
cleansing balms cleansing oils and of
course micellar waters if you want to
know more about cleansing and how to set
up a skincare routine you can check out
my book the loudmouth and guide to basic
skincare
[Music]
my seller waters are very liquid
products that contain gentle surfactants
in water you pour them onto a cotton pad
and wipe them over your skin and
generally you don't need to rinse
they're very popular for removing makeup
and for cleaning your skin when you
don't have a sink handy for my cells in
my cellar water our health surfactants
have ranged themselves into these little
clusters when they're in water oily
substances are attracted to the tails
that are in the middle of the micelles
now you might have heard some people say
that my solar water is just soapy water
or just diluted cleanser and while
technically these do have micelles in
water micellar water is a category of
product it's like how technically any
stick that you put on your lips is a lip
stick but it's not lipstick the key
difference with micellar waters is that
if they've been formulated carefully is
that they're designed to stay on your
skin the problem with a lot of
surfactants is that they're quite
irritating they tend to burrow into your
skin and stay there which causes
irritation and dehydration but different
surfactants have different irritation
potential so for example in bio dome as
micellar waters they use a surfactant
that's used in levon products like
moisturizers and so it's fine to leave
them on your skin without rinsing if you
just take any cleanser and dilute it
with water and try to use it like
micellar water you're probably leaving
surfactants on your skin that are meant
to be rinsed off so what's so good about
my sellers compared to other cleansers
the biggest advantage of my solar waters
is that they are so so convenient since
you use my solar waters with cotton pads
they tend to be better at removing
makeup than standard foaming cleansers
if you're micellar water has beneficial
ingredients in it then it acts as a
one-step cleansing and toning and
treatment step so for example Bioderma
have three types of micellar water the
sense of bio which is for sensitive skin
and the CBM which is for oily and acne
prone skin both contain GAF this is the
dermatological advanced formulation
which is a combination of actives that
make your skin more resilient to
irritation and to free radicals the
sebum also has zinc and copper which
help to fight acne there's also the
Hydra bio version which is made for
dehydration prone skin and this can
Kayne's aqua jenny 'm this is a
combination of niacinamide and apple
extract which helped to improve the
circulation of water in your skin and
repair your skin barrier there's also
tons of my favorite who met an
ingredient glycerin which is great at
holding water onto your skin predictably
by Joma hydra bio is my favorite
micellar water it's really good at
cleansing without leaving my skin
feeling tight I also like the simple
micellar water which has added
niacinamide micellar water source are
really versatile since it's not
oil-based and says you can leave it on
your skin it's really good for
correcting makeup mistakes so for
example my winged eyeliner you can dip a
cotton bud into it and then wipe away
any mistakes and because it's not
oil-based you can put makeup on it
immediately afterwards and that's
probably why makeup artists love it so
much because you don't need a sink and
you don't need to rinse it's really good
for situations like after you go to the
gym or when you're traveling especially
if you're on a plane and you have the
travel sized bottle if you're bad at
removing your makeup at night if you
leave a bottle of micelle water next to
your bed with some cotton pads then you
might be able to break that habit it's a
bit less wasteful the makeup wipes and
yes you can use reusable cotton pads
with micellar water micellar water is
also really good if you need to avoid a
certain area of your face so for example
I got my eyebrows micro bladed and after
that I couldn't get my eyebrows wet for
10 days so I got some micellar water and
cotton pads and I wiped all around it to
cleanse I don't know what I would have
done without my cell water the fact that
you don't have to rinse micellar water
is a really big advantage when you're in
areas where the tap water might not work
for your skin so for example if you have
really hard water if you have really
highly chlorinated water or if you just
have muddy and polluted and dirty water
Bioderma use ppi water which is water
that's high-quality enough to be
injected and so the water quality issue
is sorted
[Music]
of course no skin care product was for
everyone and for every situation so here
are the downsides of micellar water you
do need to use my solar waters with a
cotton pad what the cotton pad does is
that sort of unrolls for myself so the
tails which love oil can grab onto
greasy oil and makeup I have more info
on this on my video on the science
behind my seller water so the obvious
downside is you do need to have a cotton
pad around the other downside is that
cotton pads if they're a bit rough if
you're pressing it too hard if you use
it too frequently they are actually
physical exfoliants and so it's possible
to over exfoliate your skin it's also
difficult to use my cell water in the
shower so if you usually wash your face
in the shower you'll have to use them I
sell water before you go in some
Marcella waters aren't formulated to be
all that gentle and of course different
people have different skin sensitivities
so if you have sensitive skin and using
my cell water that has harsh surfactants
or if it has a really high pH and you
don't rinse it off then you might end up
with irritated skin in general the pH of
cleanses including micellar waters
should be slightly acidic around pH 4 to
6 unfortunately this isn't always the
case and you can end up with micellar
waters at high pH that can tear your
skin off I hope this video answers some
of your questions about my solar waters
if you do have a question I didn't cover
leave it in the comments if you like
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this you can also follow me on
instagram at lab wealth and beauty
science and check out my blog see you
next time for more beauty science